are you at the point now where you say
he's a [ __ ] marriage this is it i am
never i mean is marriage not for you but
at this point have you figured it out
well i'd like to say no it's not me just
by my
track record after my third divorce i uh
uh you know you it gets to a point where
you're like
what maybe it's maybe it's me after your
third abortion
no way it's you you're famous there's no
way it could be you i would say i'm
never gonna do it but
you know james cameron always said hey
you write your own [ __ ] story nobody
writes your eddie
he's been married five times and he's
this last marriage is just awesome
financially though you take this huge
hit each time
and that's got to be concerning too
because you know
let's face it i mean you you want to
have some money in your old age
you know sharon stone's a really good
friend of mine and she said uh two years
ago she was sort of by
coaching me through this because she got
through a horribly contentious divorce
with children
and she said you're going to spend every
dime you have
to get your kids i know the person
you're go i know your ex-wife
and i was like do you really think so
and she goes
what you it's not worth it you know why
you're kids you know she's tough
i read somewhere that you sold a warhol
that you owned
you actually owned a warhol painting and
because of the divorce you had to sell
it
well i sold a couple i sold those uh
during at the
towards the end of the marriage tried to
you know uh
keep it keep it alive and then i saw a
couple
after i had i had several did you go
talk to a therapist about this uh
because i would imagine you would be
bitter and angry about it you don't seem
like you are but i would imagine there's
got to be some real anger there
when i make a list and that's something
you do at therapist you make a list of
what's really
important and and down the line is
well i don't have the art anymore you
know i had a
chagall i had you know this rembrandt
that
you know i had a lot of things and i
don't have that but
i have my kids art on the wall